[Music]
this is breaking news on 8 news now 5:30
it's a Friday morning thank you for
joining us I'm John Langley we are
following some breaking news we are
following the USGS reporting more than a
dozen earthquakes up in central Nevada
near Tonopah Sheree thank you John and
I'm Cherise when Scout that's turning
into dozens now of aftershocks I can't
even get them on the map fast enough
John to keep up with the USGS now this
was all happening about four hours
northwest of Las Vegas up in a little
town called Mina you see that just up
there northwest of Tonopah now the first
quake was the biggest it was a 6.4
magnitude happened just after 4:00
o'clock this morning John yeah there
were about a dozen aftershocks as you
mentioned here they range from three
point eight to five point four the
shaking felt here in Las Vegas we've
gotten a lot of reports on Twitter about
this and online we've got some emails
this is actually from elsewhere I think
this is the one from California we got
over in Fresno people felt it in Reno in
Sacramento pretty sparsely populated
area where the earthquake is centered
but it's been felt all across a good
chunk of the California and Nevada state
line Jerry right they say they felt it
all the way up to Ely Elko over to
Sacramento down to Fresno as we're
showing the video there and then right
here in Southern Nevada some folks in
Las Vegas and even over in Pahrump in
southern Knight County so we've got
someone on the phone from prompt
Stephanie Sanchez who lives in Pahrump
she's a booking a manager for
entertainment with MGM Resorts good
morning Stephanie good morning so tell
us you and I chatted a little bit and
you told me that this one shook you
awake what did you what did you feel
there this morning it did it felt like I
haven't I haven't checked the time but
it felt like about 10 to 15 seconds it
was shaking woken up the lights were
gone and the glasses rattling and I have
plenty of time to think what glasses was
I gonna try to save first as I thought
something was gonna fall but it woke up
everybody in the households the animals
are fine my
to serve with next door and I called her
and it woke them up I called my niece up
in Reno and I woke them up as well it
was like we keep hearing from yeah from
people we're talking to is that it just
woke them out of a complete dead sleep
and no damage that we've heard of did
you have any damage you say your glass
was rattling and things were shaking but
any damage there and in the Pahrump area
that you know of no I've been checking
around and I ever see any damage not
around the house farm animals out here
as well and I went checked on them and
they were fine my dog didn't even move
well peaches didn't move at all but the
animals are fine just a lot of shaking
okay and that these temblors that's what
they seem to do roll and shake a lot and
just scary feeling
last question have you been through
earthquakes before oh well I'm from here
so only the ones that are here we felt
and of all the ones that have been going
on this morning we just felt the two the
first one was really strong the second
one we could feel the swing but it was
much more gentle okay well you guys stay
safe there in southern Knight County and
we'll we'll keep everyone posted on
what's going on up there around Tonopah
thanks um